papa was ist das für ein tier
das ist ein nashorn
das nashorn ist groß schwer
aber es kann trotzdem sehr schnell
rennen
ja aber es kann trotzdem sehr schnell
papa
was ist das für ein tier
papa was ist das für ein tier
das ist eine giraffe
die giraffe hat einen langen hals
die giraffe hat ein
ja
graphen
hälse damit sie die blätter von den
bäumen fressen können
ja giraffen
haben lange hälse damit sie die blätter
von den bäumen fressen können
papa schau die katze so süß
nein das ist keine katze das ist ein
tiger
der tiger sieht aber aus wie eine katze
ja aber der tiger ist gefährlich
er hat große zähne und scharfe krallen
[Musik]
geh nicht so nah
an den käfig
[Musik]
er ist aber trotzdem süß
gehen nicht zu nahe an den zaun
gehe nicht zu nahe an den zaun
was ist das für ein tier
das ist ein affe
der affe kann gut klettern
gut klettern
das macht er da
er sucht die läuse in seinem fell und
frisst sie
und das was ist das für ein tier
das ist ein kamel
das kamel hat ein problem mit seinem
rücken
nein ein kamel hat zwei höcker
ein kamel hat zwei höcker
kamele können zwei wochen überleben ohne
wasser zu trinken
wow und die menschen wie lange können
wir leben ohne zu trinken
menschen sterben nach drei tagen ohne
wasser
schau mal was ist das
das ist ein nilpferd
das lied vergiss es
[Musik]
ja
auch gefährlich
[Musik]
die pferde können sehr aggressiv werden
nilpferde können sehr aggressiv werden
das dort ist ein krokodil stimmt's
ja richtig
krokodil
gefährlich
[Musik]
ja richtig krokodile sind gefährlich
das krokodil hat einen
großen mund und scharfe zähne
mund und scharfe zähne
ich habe angst vor dem krokodil
angst vor dem krokodil
schau da dort ist eine schlange
die schlange ist giftig
vorsichtig
ja
und da ist eine schildkröte
sie hat einen dicken
sie hat einen dicken panzer
unsere lehrerin hat gesagt dass
schildkröten sehr alt werden können
unsere lehrer
unsere lehrerin sehr alte alt
unsere lehrerin unsere lehrerin sehr alt
sehr alt
nein unsere lehrerin ist jung
unsere lehrerin ist um unsere lehrerin
ist dumm
ein
ein junge
so ein freche papagei
frechen papagei
schau mal papa der papagei hat so schöne
farbige federn
dort ist ein bär
er versteckt sich hinter dem gebüsch
so süß
der bär ist zwar süß aber er kann
menschen töten
schau mal dort sind pinguine
sind pinguine
sind pinguine vögel
ja
der pinguin ist ein vogel
pinguin ist ein vogel
aber nicht fliegen
kann aber nicht fliegen
[Musik]
auf ihr kann er sehr gut schwimmen und
ist im wasser sehr wendig
dafür kann er sehr gut schwimmen und im
wasser sehr wendig
komm jetzt gehen wir zum streichelzoo
dort im gehege kannst du die tiere
streicheln
sie sind zutraulich und an menschen
gewöhnt
sind zutraulich und an menschen gewöhnt
kennst du die tiere
ja
eine ziege
ja das dort ist eine ziege
dort ist ein schaf
es hat weiche wolle es hat weiche wolle
dort ist ein kleines pferd
es ist so süß
braucht ist ein hund
dort ist ein hund
er band
er band dort ist ein huhn
dort ist ein huhn
es legt ein ei
dort ist ein meerschwein
dort ist dann mehr schwein
es ist so klein
dort ist ein hase
er kann hoch springen und hat lange
ohren
kann hoch springen und hat lange ohren
sehr gut gehen ins gehege
ich hole uns ein eis
hast du eine frage schreibt eine frage
in die kommentare wir werden sie
beantworten
hast du eine frage schreibt eine frage
in die kommentare wir werden sie
beantworten
habt ihr das video gefallen abonniere
unseren kanal hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal